[موسيقى]
مرحبًا ،
اسمي إيلا ستيفنز ، عمري 13
عامًا وأنا قسيس بريطاني للكارتينج
[موسيقى] لقد
بدأت الكارتينج عندما كنت في السادسة من
عمري في سيارة بامبينو
في مسار في ويلز حيث كان علي الذهاب لأول مرة
لقد أحببت ذلك حقًا ، لقد كان أخي
وأبي دائمًا في رياضة السيارات
عندما كان أخي يمارس السباق ، وكنت
أصغر كثيرًا ، لذلك كنت في الحقيقة
فقط أشاهد سباق أخي
[موسيقى]
ربما كان الجزء المفضل لدي هو السرعة
لأنها دائمًا  مجرد شيء
أتطلع إليه عندما تسير على الطريق الصحيح
وأنت تنتظر على الشبكة ،
لا أشعر بالخوف كثيرًا ولكن في
كلتا الحالتين ، أركز فقط على
[الموسيقى]
السباق
أعتقد أنه أمر مذهل تمامًا
أنهم يريدون
اتخاذ إجراءات إيجابية لزيادة
التنوع بين الجنسين في الرياضة ،
إنه شيء ندعمه ،
كما تعلم أننا نريد زيادة
جميع مستويات التنوع في
الرياضة التي تعرفها
والإجراءات التي نتبعها  أخذ من
خلال مختلف الشركات التابعة
ل e  لكترو ، تعلمون أن
رياضة السيارات هي أن قطعة الكارتون هي
أن
الأكاديمية تدور حول التنوع ،
لقد رأيت الكثير من الفتيات
يدخلن في الكارتينغ كثيرًا
عندما أذهب للسباق ، لقد رأيت بعضًا
أكثر في نفس الشبكة مثل  لي الآن بعد أن
بدأت مرة أخرى
لك